He was the undisputed king of rock n’ roll.
In the mid-1950s, 20-year old Elvis Presley
exploded onto the airwaves.
With a rockabilly blend of country music and
blues, his curled lip, and his trademark wiggling
hips, the southern boy caused a sensation.
Coming just as youth culture was taking off,
Elvis was everything these new teenagers wanted:
dangerous, rebellious, and anathema to their
parents.
Across the nation, preachers denounced him
from their pulpits.
Judges issued writs against him for corrupting
morals.
The National Guard was even called to his
concerts.
If you were alive in 1956, then you likely
thought Elvis either the sexiest or most-dangerous
man alive.
Yet who feels that way today?
Mention Elvis’s name now, and you’re more
likely to conjure images of a fat, sweaty
dude warbling away in Las Vegas, his preposterous
white suit still stained with the grease of
ten thousand hamburgers.
How did the King of rock n’ roll transform
into its blubbery punchline?
Today, Biographics is taking its Delorean
all the way back to the 1950s to witness the
birth of a generation… and the life of that
generation’s greatest icon.
(TITLE): Livin’ in a Shotgun Shack
Although he grew up to become the King, there
was nothing noble about the story of Elvis’s
birth.
On January 8, 1935, Elvis Aaron Presley was
born into a world that was groaning under
the weight of the Great Depression.
His father, Vernon Presley, was an odd-job
man, while his mother, Gladys, was barely
scraping by.
The two lived in East Tupelo, a small town
known back then as one of the roughest places
in Mississippi.
Although the family did have their own house
- a two room shotgun shack practically small
enough to fit inside your average briefcase
- it was without electricity, indoor plumbing,
or much of anything else.
In fact, the Presleys were so poor that they
had to rely on welfare to pay the doctor who
delivered Elvis.
Or rather, delivered Elvis and his twin.
Yep, twin.
Elvis was originally meant to be brother to
Jesse Garon Presley, but the younger twin
emerged stillborn.
He almost wasn’t the early one.
The birth nearly killed both Gladys and Elvis,
and the two were rushed to hospital.
Although both pulled through, the shock of
losing Jesse seems to have permanently scarred
Gladys.
For the rest of her life, she would be ferociously
overprotective of Elvis.
But that was all for the future.
For the first part of his life, baby Elvis
experienced nothing but nonstop deprivation.
Gladys and Vernon were so poor that they had
to rely on their neighbors to buy diapers.
Shockingly, this was their financial highpoint.
In 1938, Vernon was jailed for forging a $4
check, and their shack was repossessed.
As Gladys moved about, staying with friends,
three year old Elvis took to sitting on the
front steps, bawling his eyes out for his
dad to come home.
Yet, even after Vernon’s early 1939 release
for good behavior, things still didn’t improve
for the family.
They spent years bouncing between different
rental places, moving in and out of public
assistance housing.
There’s a great little legend attached to
this.
Aged four, Elvis is supposed to have overheard
his parents arguing about money, and told
them not to worry, because he’d buy them
a cadillac one day for sure.
Needless to say, this childish boast would
turn out to be more accurate than Vernon or
Gladys could’ve ever predicted.
And so life passed.
Vernon continued doing odd-jobs, the family
continued wallowing in poverty, and Elvis
finally started school.
But, even now, there were signs of the legend
he would become.
In 1945, one of Elvis’s teachers overheard
him singing.
She was so impressed by his voice that she
took him to the principal, who was so impressed
he insisted Elvis enter a talent show.
That was how, on October 3, ten year old Elvis
came to stand up at the Mississippi-Alabama
Fair and Dairy Show and sing “Old Shep.”
The event was broadcast on WELO Radio, the
first time the world - or Mississippi, at
any rate - heard Elvis Presley’s voice.
While we’d love to tell you that some stock
character in the studio immediately cried
“gadzooks!
This kid’s got something!”, the reality
was that nothing so narratively pleasing happened.
Instead, Elvis placed a paltry fifth in the
talent show, and that was that.
Except, of course, it wasn’t.
On Elvis’s 11th birthday, Gladys took him
to buy a present.
Elvis was determined to either get a rifle
or a bike, but both gifts were so dangerous
that just thinking about them gave the overprotective
Gladys palpitations.
So she convinced her son to make do with a
cheaper gift instead, one which would keep
him out of trouble.
And that’s how, in January, 1946, Elvis
Presley got his first guitar.
(TITLE): Home of the Blues
The next big shift in young Elvis’s life
came in November, 1948.
That month, Vernon and Gladys moved all the
way north to Memphis, hoping for a fresh start.
For their music-loving son, it was like spending
your entire life listening to only one tune,
only to suddenly discover Spotify exists and,
dear God, music is everywhere!
Although the family were still in public housing,
it was now in a city thrumming with blues,
with country, with gospel, with anything that
might make you dance.
At school, too, the new city meant a new Elvis.
Suddenly, the boy was wearing his hair long
- well, long for the fifties - and slicked
back, and pairing it with colorful, stylish
outfits.
Out went Elvis, the momma’s boy and teacher’s
pet.
In came Elvis: the rock n’ roll rebel.
At least, that was the image.
In reality, Elvis pretty much stayed out of
trouble, despite what his swagger might’ve
suggested.
OK, so let’s jump forward a few years now;
past the end of the forties, past the Korean
War, and right on to the summer of 1953, where
Elvis has just graduated and got a job driving
trucks.
At this point, America is on the cusp of becoming
what you imagine when you think “1950s USA”.
The portable transistor radio was months away
from debuting.
Little Richard had just signed with Peacock
Records, and rock n’ roll was slowly becoming
a Thing.
Teens were starting to become consumers, leading
to the first ripples of youth culture.
In short, it was a world transforming, with
a new, teen-led culture just waiting for its
leader.
It would find him in Memphis.
That summer, 1953, Elvis got a $4 advance
from his job and went to the Memphis Recording
Service to cut a single.
In later years, the King would say he simply
wanted to hear what he sounded like.
But since the service was owned by Sun Records’
Sam Phillips, it seems more likely that Elvis
wanted to get noticed.
Not that that immediately happened.
After famously telling the assistant at the
service “I don’t sound like nobody,”
Elvis cut his record, paid his four bucks…
...and nothing.
For a whole year Elvis waited, driving trucks
and hoping for the best.
At some point in those twelve months, he must’ve
started to wonder if his music career was
gonna go anywhere.
Then, on June 26, 1954, he finally got the
call.
Marion Keisker at Sun Records wanted to know
if he could be at the studio by three.
As Elvis later said: “I was there by the
time she hung up the phone.”
The session Elvis sang in that day wasn’t
great, but it was good enough for Sam Phillips
to call him back on July 5.
That day, nothing much seemed to be happening
in the booth.
No magic, no nothing.
Bummed out, everyone took a break.
And that’s when it happened.
To unwind, Elvis casually started playing
a version of Arthur Crudup’s blues song
That’s All Right, only with a faster tempo
and a laid back style.
As he played, session guitarist Scotty Moore
and bassist Bill Black joined in.
Suddenly, the song was transformed into something
more than blues.
Into a whole new sound.
The trio cut their single that same day.
None of them could’ve known it as they left
the studio and stepped out into the warm Memphis
evening, but they’d just found their golden
ticket.
When That’s All Right hit the airwaves,
it was gonna transform their lives.
(TITLE): That was the Summer of ‘54…
When fame came for Elvis, it didn’t slowly
court him.
It grabbed him like some kind of out-of-control
fame hawk, dragging him straight up into the
stratosphere.
On July 8, local station WHBQ was handed Elvis’s
record by Sam Phillips and asked to play it.
When they did, the switchboard lit up like
a Christmas tree.
So many people called in, that WHBQ played
That’s All Right again.
And again.
By the time the show ended, Elvis’s record
had been heard all over the state.
People were going nuts.
From that point on, Elvis’s destiny was
fixed.
He was gonna be the biggest damn star Memphis
had ever seen.
That summer was a wild one for the boy and
his musicians.
From driving trucks, Elvis was suddenly being
driven all over Tennessee, all over the Deep
South, playing endless gigs.
Because they only had that one record, that’s
all they played.
Johnny Cash later recalled seeing Elvis at
one gig just sing That’s All Right over
and over, like a record stuck on repeat.
Yet people loved it.
Try and image, for a moment, how it must’ve
felt to be Elvis Presley that summer.
How it must’ve felt, driving from town to
town, the windows rolled down and a cool breeze
blowing through your slicked-back hair, knowing
that your time had come.
It must’ve been magical.
The sort of feeling you can’t ever recapture.
On October 16, Elvis played the Louisiana
Hayride radio show, his voice transmitting
to 13 states.
The response was so good that the producers
had him sign a year-long contract then and
there.
It meant enough money to quit his day job.
But Hayride is important in the Elvis story
for another reason.
A month after Elvis began his contract, a
shady music promoter began working with Hayride.
A guy who claimed he came from West Virginia,
but couldn’t quite hide his Dutch accent.
Yep, it’s time to introduce Colonel Tom
Parker.
A major impresario in the south, Parker is
a guy with a background so strange it’s
tempting to think he stepped out a Hollywood
noir.
He claimed to be American, but was really
from the Netherlands.
His title of colonel was only honorary, and
the one time he’d really been in the Army
he’d deserted.
His past was full of weird tales, like running
carnival roadshows or intentionally eating
until he was too fat to fight in WWII.
He likely wasn’t a naturalized US citizen;
and it’s even thought today he may have
fled the Netherlands after killing someone.
But Parker did have one vital skill.
He knew talent when he saw it.
And he knew how to make that talent a household
name.
Elvis finally met Parker on January 15, 1955.
Immediately, Parker began to muscle into the
young man’s career, pushing Elvis’ other
manager out the picture.
At times, this was done via ballsy moves,
like stumping up $10,000 of his own money
to buy Elvis out his Sun Records contract
so he could move to the bigger label RCA.
At others, it was done via almost sociopathic
behavior.
Within days of James Dean’s death in a car
wreck that September, Parker was on the phone
to Warner Bros., insisting they just stick
Elvis in any unfinished Dean films.
But if Elvis disapproved of these methods
- or of the man himself - he didn’t show
it.
On November 21, 1955, Elvis signed the RCA
contract Parker had negotiated.
It netted him $5,000, plus a guarantee that
he’d play on television within 60 days.
On January 28, 1956, Elvis sang for the first
time to a national audience on CBS’s Stage
Show.
At the time, Elvis was a mere 20-years old.
By the time he turned 21, he would be the
biggest star on
the planet.
(TITLE): The
King
of Controversy
When Elvis arrived on the national stage,
it was amid a whirlwind of controversy.
We don’t just mean as a white guy playing
black music, although that annoyed plenty.
We mean something almost more concerning to
1950s prudes.
Elvis was sexy.
You know those images of Beatlemania, with
teenage girls screaming their heads off for
any Beatle who wasn’t Ringo?
That was Elvis in 1956.
Something about the way he wiggled his hips
just seemed to send teenage uteruses wild.
And that meant sending the parents of those
teenagers into meltdown.
At a concert in Jacksonville, Florida, a judge
issued a pre-emptive arrest warrant against
Elvis for “impairing the morals of minors”
should he swivel his hips in the state.
In his hometown of Tupelo, a hundred National
Guardsmen surrounded the stage to stop a riot
from breaking out.
This wasn’t music.
It was something dangerous.
The oral equivalent of James Dean in Rebel
Without a Cause.
But Elvis had the good luck to ride this cultural
wave just as the mainstream caught on.
At the beginning of 1956, an outraged Ed Sullivan
declared he’d never have Elvis on his show.
By September, Elvis was playing the Ed Sullivan
Show before an estimated 60 million people
- 80 percent of the viewing audience.
1956-Elvis may have started out dangerous
and sexy, but the mainstream was already embracing
him.
Making him rich, but also leaving him about
as edgy as Dennis the Menace.
By January, 1957, Ed Sullivan was even telling
his viewers that Elvis “is a decent, fine
boy.”
But the real nail in his rebel coffin arrived
in December.
That was the month Elvis was drafted.
The King may have played the rebel onstage
but, when it came down to it, he was a polite
Southern patriot.
He accepted his commission without complaint.
For teens in the grip of Elvismania, this
was the cultural equivalent of Armageddon.
Tens of thousands of letters flooded the draft
board, begging for Elvis to be exempted.
But the King wanted to go.
On 24 March, 1958, Elvis reported for duty.
His hair and sideburns were shorn off in front
of the cameras, and he was packed off for
basic training.
Before he went, Colonel Parker made the boy
record a ton of singles to be slowly released
over the next two years, to stop his star
from fading away.
But while Parker would succeed in keeping
Elvis in the public’s mind, he wouldn’t
be able to maintain the sexy aura Elvis had
projected just a couple of years before.
That was now gone forever.
Over in Germany, Elvis began the newest, and
perhaps ickiest chapter of his life.
In September, 1959, the 24-year old star met
Priscilla Beaulieu, who you’ll know better
as the future Priscilla Presley.
The problem?
In 1959, Priscilla was only 14.
And so we come to the most difficult part
of today’s video.
It’s true that this was a different time.
Jerry Lee Lewis, Chuck Berry, Charlie Chaplin
and - over the next decade and a half - Jimmy
Page, David Bowie, and Iggy Pop would all
have similar underage relationships.
On the other hand, a man in his twenties having
a relationship with a girl of 14 was as immoral
then as it is now.
And Elvis seemed to know this.
Although he and Priscilla did many things
together, they always stopped short of sex
- presumably so Elvis could avoid a statuatory
rape charge.
The worst of Elvis’s behavior is usually
attributed to his later-life drug addiction.
But his seduction of an underage girl suggests
there were problems that stemmed from someplace
much darker.
The King’s stint in the army finally ended
on March 2, 1960.
That day, he was put on a military transport
and flown back to the States.
Just weeks later, he cut the Elvis is Back
album.
After two long years in the wilderness, the
King had finally returned.
(TITLE): “What happened to good old rock
'n' roll?”
The Sixties were a weird time to be Elvis.
On the one hand, this was the decade when
he became so stinking rich that he never had
to worry about money again.
On the other hand, it was also the decade
when things started going a little… weird.
Let’s tackle the successes first.
Between 1960 and 1968, Elvis released some
30 movies; nearly all of them bringing him,
the studio, and Colonel Tom Parker a tidy
profit.
He also kept recording hits, although these
were rarely “hits” in the era-defining
way That’s All Right had been.
Still, Elvis and his family comfortably entered
the 1%, allowing him to finally marry the
no-longer-underage Priscilla in Las Vegas
in 1967.
Less than a year later, their daughter, Lisa
Marie Presley, was born.
OK, that’s the highlights.
Now let’s dig into the less-good stuff.
Although Elvis was doing well financially,
the movies and songs bringing that money in
were… not great.
Artistically, watching 60s’ Elvis was like
watching Michelangelo follow up the Sistine
Chapel by dedicating his life to paintings
of dogs playing poker.
You can admire the craft, but… really?
The slump in Elvis’s taste can be easily
seen in his legendary 1965 meeting with the
Beatles.
Although he and the Fab Four eventually had
a good time jamming together, John Lennon’s
opening remark to the King was:
“'Why do you do all these soft-centred ballads
for the cinema these days?
What happened to good old rock 'n' roll?'”
It’s not the only nail Lennon hit squarely
on the head that day.
After their jam session, Lennon told people
that Elvis had been stoned the entire time.
Although the King’s hefty drug use is usually
said to have started later, it seems by the
mid-60s he was already on that slippery slope.
It was also during the ‘60s that Elvis likely
began to develop his eating disorder.
The first references come from the start of
the decade, with interviewers remarking how
Elvis liked to eat piles of junk food.
Before the ‘60s were out, the King was turning
to comfort eating more and more.
We’ve read people say that, when he was
feeling low, eating was the only thing that
could make Elvis feel normal again.
Even his new marriage had its dark side.
For whatever weird reason, Elvis was obsessed
with virginity.
Priscilla later told an interviewer that Elvis:
“had mentioned to me before we were married
that he had never been able to make love to
a woman who had a child.”
And that hangup remained.
After Lisa Marie Presley was born, Elvis never
had sex with Priscilla again.
Within a few years, the lack of contact would
drive Priscilla to have an affair that would
end their marriage.
Yet, despite all this, the decade ended on
something of a high.
In early 1968, Tom Parker had cut a deal with
NBC to do a bland one hour special of Elvis
singing Christmas songs.
But when the project got underway, it slipped
out the Colonel’s control, and instead became
a music industry legend.
Sick of being a bland mass entertainer, Elvis
concocted something that would become known
as the ‘68 Comeback Special.
Clad in black leather, his figure once again
trim, Elvis strode onto the stage, for the
last time exuding cool.
In a wide-ranging set, he rocked the classics,
did some unplugged acoustic, and engaged in
banter with the audience.
By the time the curtain went down, over 42
percent of the nation had tuned in to watch,
and the feeling was undeniable.
1956 Elvis - sexy, dangerous Elvis - was back.
But it was a fleeting moment.
A last gasp of rock n’ roll from a bygone
performer.
A few months later, Elvis began his residency
at the Las Vegas International Hotel, getting
paid $1m annually to entertain tourists over
their lobster dinner.
And so, in the big fight in Elvis’ head
between commercial success and artistic expression,
it was commercial success which won.
(TITLE): The King is Gone (but not forgotten)
The last 8 years of Elvis’s life were like
watching a slow-motion clown-car crash; disturbing,
but also kind of darkly amusing.
By Christmas, 1970, Elvis was so rich and
so weird that he was able to spend $100,000
on 32 handguns and 10 Mercedes as a present
to himself.
When Priscilla hit the roof, he stormed out
the house, got on a jet to Washington and
declared that he wanted to meet the President.
Which is how Elvis Presley came to be photographed
shaking hands with Richard Nixon, who was
so grateful he gave the King a badge from
the federal Bureau of Narcotics and Dangerous
Drugs.
By now, the once-polite Southern boy was rich
enough to do whatever he wanted, surrounded
by toadying yes men, and deep into a drug
habit.
And what he wanted to do was keep on digging
deeper.
In February, 1972, Elvis and Priscilla separated,
with their divorce coming through a year later.
With his wife and child gone, Elvis seems
to have lost the last rope tethering him to
planet Earth.
Oh, sure, he still packed out the International
in Las Vegas.
He still found time to record late hits like
Suspicious Minds.
But his life was by now simply one long-delayed
suicide attempt.
By 1975, Elvis was living as an almost total
recluse in Graceland, only waking up long
after the sun had set, like some junk food-addicted
vampire.
Speaking of junk food, what had begun as comfort
eating had by now become an ugly obsession.
Elvis’s favorite late-life snack was Fool’s
Gold Loaf, which involves taking a whole loaf
of hollowed-out bread, and cramming it full
of peanut butter, jelly, and half a kilo of
bacon, before deep-frying the whole thing.
The average male consumes around 2,500 calories
a day.
A single Fool’s Gold Loaf contains over
8,000.
And Elvis never stopped with just a single
loaf.
In his last few months, Elvis started living
with 21-year old Ginger Alden, who witnessed
his behavior degenerate into pure self-destruction.
He would do stuff like fire his handguns at
the TV.
Once, he put a bullet into the wall next to
her head when she tried to make him stop eating
yoghurt.
Remember earlier, when we tried to imagine
what it must’ve been like to be Elvis in
the summer of 1954?
Well, let’s try again now.
Try to imagine what it must’ve felt like
to be trapped in this sagging body.
Locked away in Graceland, never seeing daylight.
Your soul nothing but an empty void you keep
trying to fill with food and pills.
Now compare those two mental images and ask
yourself: what the hell happened?
Finally, all the abuse got too much for Elvis’s
body.
On August 16, 1977, the King died in the bathroom
of his Graceland mansion; allegedly while
sat on the throne.
He was only 42 years old.
When the news broke that the King was gone,
mourners gathered in vast crowds at Graceland.
Although the man who’d died had been a bloated,
drug addicted mess, that wasn’t the man
they were there to remember.
They were there to remember the boy who, for
a few short years in the 1950s, had changed
their lives; opened them up a new and dangerous
thing called rock n’ roll.
As Bruce Springsteen later said of Elvis’s
early years: “It was like he whispered his
dream in all our ears and then we dreamed
it.”
Today, the jury is still out on Elvis Presley.
For every person whose teenage years were
lit up by his voice, there is someone else
who only ever saw him as the sweaty fat guy
in Vegas, the bygone buffoon who died while
taking a crap.
Yet there’s no doubt that Elvis was an important
figure.
Here was a man who almost single-handedly
forged an entire era in pop culture.
Take away Elvis and you have no Beatles.
No Rolling Stones.
No foundation for modern music.
He may have done some morally dubious things.
He may have ended his life as a parody of
his former self.
But there’s no doubt that Elvis deserves
to be remembered not as a joke, but as that
young man in the summer of 1954, the window
rolled down as he drives to his next gig,
ready to change
the world.